what did I do this weekend I watched
Rome that's it that's all I did and
whatever I show it makes me feel that
slothful makes me feel okay with it it's
like sitting in my room only watching
that show and doing nothing else for an
entire weekend figured that your show
we're talking about
Rome so Rome was a show on HBO lasted
two seasons and that's it
short story because it was an absurdly
expensive show like twice as much as
Game of Thrones kind of expensive and
since you know the entire world didn't
watch the show I guess not enough people
watched it so they had to cancel it
doesn't mean it wasn't awesome now
season one starts out when Rome was
still a republic Julius Caesar was
running the show and it pretty much
deals with Julius Caesar's rise to power
and Rome's transition from a republic to
an empire so for all you people who
thought Revenge of the Sith did it well
watch Rome and see how Republic really
transitions into an empire and I figure
people out there should probably know
how julius caesar's reign came to a
complete and sudden stop but for those
of you who don't I won't spoil it for
you even though if you don't know slap
your history teacher so season one ends
right there and for season two I was
like what can they do now how can it be
interesting and it was because there's
so much stuff that happened after season
one but since you have to have a couple
characters who pretty much see the
events as you see em we have Ray
Stevenson play and titus pullo and Kevin
McKidd playing Lucius Vorenus two
friends who don't really start out as
friends but their war buddies and their
friends so like the way more awesomely
hardcore versions of r2d2 and c3po
alright maybe kind of more hardcore than
r2 but way more than c-3po Arty's badass
the show really focuses on those two and
it does a really good job but planting
them in these really iconic moments in
Roman history but still keeping them out
of history you know like it could have
happened but you know it didn't might
have lucius vorenus is just hardcore
dude whenever Kevin McKidd zall like you
shut your mouth you know you're
like alright Vorenus is business there's
no way that guy will go on to be the
journey man you can't help but like like
90% of the characters even the
characters you're not supposed to like
and you're supposed to hate you kind of
like sometimes like Mark Antony you're
not supposed to like him he's a total
douchebag but once in a while
he'll say or do something where you're
like that guy's awesome maybe I'm a
douche bag I don't know and all
the women from my facebook just now
we're like eh yeah you are I love you
too there's this one kid in there I was
like that kid must be someone I didn't
know who he was but I was like he's too
awesome and smart to be just nobody so I
looked him up and I was like these that
guy that's awesome not going to tell you
who but if you played civilization 5 oh
you know and yeah it's on HBO which
means it's the most graphic show I've
ever seen in my life yeah more than Game
of Thrones graphic I mean we're talking
sex violence nudity you can pass it off
as yeah it's Rome that's just how it was
doesn't mean it's not in there a lot so
for those of you who stick to pg-13
might want to pass on Rome but you'll be
doing yourself a disservice yeah it's
really graphic I'll season ones pretty
consistent you're like oh yeah it starts
out at eight ends at Z season two there
was something about it where I was like
dude it skips years and doesn't tell you
it's because season two pretty much
encompasses what they wanted season two
three and four to be I just kind of
funneled it and they were like alright
well that's just season two that's how
we need to end the show you see a couple
things happen in season two and you're
like why'd they even have that and
you're like oh yeah they're probably
setting up for season three but it just
never happened like I guess the one to
bring Jesus into it about season three
or four then this one setting the stage
it's like oh yeah Jews and rum all right
moving on like oh okay that was that
story arc that went nowhere they wanted
like an entire season to deal with Egypt
and Mark Antony and Cleopatra in season
two it's like two episodes talk to that
it kind of depresses you you're like
that would have been so awesome to see
in the scope that they wanted to show it
but when you're watching the show and
you just see the sets you're like yeah
the show is clearly canceled because of
the budget that's why I never watch
Spartacus blood and Stan because I saw
the previews and I was like wow that's a
lot of CGI and rum there's only a couple
parts where I'm like yeah that's shot on
a green-screen usually it's this wide
scope shot of like the water and boats
and ships and things like that because
if Waterworld taught us anything is that
shooting on water is expensive I guess
the sets on rome look every bit as legit
as like gladiator this last weekend I
watched it for the first time in years I
felt like an for not watching it
every year
Rome is awesome tacular I'm telling you
guys you should watch it if you like
empires and republics and political
scheming it's not civilized culture it's
wrong you should probably check it out
I'm just saying so have you seen Rome
what did you think of it if you haven't
seen Rome what's your favorite show on
HBO right now or ever comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more
you